[Applause]
[Music]
on the battlefield the war in Ukraine
has been a major failure for Russia even
so this is not the only bad political
military news the Kremlin has endured
lately one of the main arguments Moscow
used to try to justify its atrocious
invasion was to prevent NATO from
continuing to expand Eastward at all
costs according to the Russian
government this was an absolutely
unacceptable risk for them yet today
visualpolitik viewers things have taken
a 180 degree turn the invasion of
Ukraine made countries like Finland and
Sweden think about changing their status
if up until now they had preferred to
stay independent The Invasion convinced
them that this was no longer advisable
they had to join NATO Finland did so in
April 2023. tomorrow we will um welcome
Finland as the 31st member of NATO
making Finland safer and our alliance
stronger we will race The Finnish flag
for the first time here at the NATO
headquarters Sweden however has had it
much harder until now
[Music]
in the end and despite all the back and
forth that we will get into in this
video Sweden will become the 32nd member
of the Atlantic Alliance and pay
attention because this is not something
that Russia is at all amused about in
fact check out their typical reactions
over the years Russian Ambassador if
Sweden joins NATO there will be
consequences Putin pointed out that
there will be consequences that Russia
will have to resort to a military type
response and redirect our troops and
missiles Russia simulated nuclear attack
on Sweden NATO admits with an area of
about 174 000 square miles or 450 000
square kilometers and almost 11 million
inhabitants Sweden is the third largest
country in the European Union and the
great Scandinavian Powerhouse the
question is why is Sweden of such
concern to the Kremlin what exactly does
the inclusion of this country mean for
NATO is this really something that
Russia should be concerned about what
will change from now on well in this
video we're going to answer all these
questions and to understand this whole
story the first thing we need to do is
to start at the very beginning so let's
get on with it
[Music]
from Empire to neutrality
in culture and in the popular
imagination we tend to see Sweden as a
calm and moderate State a Bastion of
social peace and a place synonymous with
modern social democracy of course this
was not always the case this country's
past was much more intimidating the
Swedish Empire was one of the most
powerful European powers of the 17th
century at that time its territory also
included present-day Finland Estonia and
a large part of Norway but the question
is why are we telling you this on
visualpolitik well because the
configuration of the current territory
in this region of Europe responds to the
events caused by what is known as the
Great Northern war we're talking about a
conflict that took place between 1700
and 1721. during those years the Swedish
Empire maintained an armed conflict
against Russia Denmark and Norway they
were fighting for Supremacy in the
Baltic Sea
the conflict ended with the Treaty of
neistat in 1721. with this treaty Sweden
was beaten down by Russian tsarism and
that's not all a few decades later
between 1808 and 1809 the so-called
Finnish war broke out where Russia again
prevailed over Sweden following that war
the grand duchy of Finland came under
the control of Russia
[Music]
and so little by little Russia became a
great Baltic power the sea ceased to be
a kind of exclusive Lake of the Swedish
Empire and over time became the natural
Outlet of the Russian Fleet to the Seas
of the world
for its part Sweden starting in the 19th
century and after having lost its former
Imperial Grandeur adopted a policy of
neutrality the reorganization of the
state and the development of the country
became its main priorities we're talking
about a neutrality that for more than
150 years was basically only called into
question during the second world war
questioned but not broken officially
Sweden did not join either side and
later in 1949 when World War II had
already given way to the Cold War
Stockholm opted to stay out of NATO and
declared a security policy based on
Independence and neutrality
in the 1990s however a wave of
pro-european enthusiasm swept over
Sweden so that in 1995 the country
finally decided to break with its
historical stake policy and joined the
European Union what's more although it
remained outside NATO it did strengthen
its ties with this organization for
example during all these years it has
participated as an affiliate as an ally
but not as a member in NATO missions in
Bosnia Kosovo Afghanistan and Libya
and there's even more in 2007 Sweden
joined Finland Norway Estonia Ireland
Latvia and Lithuania in the Nordic
battle group nbg one of the European
Union's battle groups whose headquarters
are in the Swedish town of encurping a
reserve group of 2 400 soldiers from
these countries is based there
[Music]
in other words Swedish neutrality began
to disappear at full speed something
that believe it or not Vladimir Putin
had nothing to do with and what you may
ask did the Russian leader do well
basically he did what he does best he
launched a constant campaign of
intimidation his goal to prevent Sweden
from joining the Atlantic Alliance at
all costs Russian military actions in
the Baltic unprecedented polish defense
minister Thomas simonayak said most of
the activity took place on international
waters and airspace and Sweden was the
most affected country Sweden intercepts
Russian military aircraft flying with
their transponders turned off over the
Baltic region Russia beefs up Baltic
Fleet amid NATO tensions Sweden's
defense minister said his country was
concerned about the warship's presence
in the Baltic Sea and complained that
the move would likely keep tensions in
the region high but why does Russia care
so much about what countries like
Finland or Sweden might do we'll get to
that in a moment in this very video and
as I've already mentioned the
implications of Swedish and Finnish
membership are much greater than we
might imagine but for now what we have
to be clear about is that the Russian
strategy has not worked the invasion of
Ukraine Unleashed unexpected
consequences for Russia if the kremlin's
goal was to put its foot down in the end
fear of the irrationality of the Russian
bear made both Finland and Sweden
understand that all that talk of
neutrality and going it alone was no
longer an option being part of NATO was
the only real way to guarantee their
security and guess what as we say around
here no sooner said than done the NATO
flag is already flying at the bases in
Helsinki but why has Sweden's accession
to Nato taken so long well basically
because there were pending accounts what
exactly are we talking about well we're
going to look at that right now
[Music]
[Applause]
pitfalls on the road
visual politic community
but for a country to join NATO all its
members have to agree and give their
approval with Finland that was
relatively easy but in the case of
Sweden well let's just say that two NATO
member countries were determined to make
things not so simple the first country
has been erdogan's turkey for months the
Turkish government has alleged that
Sweden was backing and harboring
militants from Kurdish organizations
that the Turkish government considers
terrorist groups and enemies of the
state in addition until September 2022
Sweden too it maintained an embargo on
arms sales against turkey because of
turkey's operations in Northern Syria
and of course with those two precedents
it was clear that negotiations were not
going to be a piece of cake nevertheless
on 11th September 2022 there was a
change of political color in Sweden the
government changed from the social
Democrats to a coalition of conservative
parties a change that facilitated the
passage of a new anti-terrorism law that
among other things limited to Swedish
support for the Kurdish cause later in
October delegates from the Swedish and
Turkish Justice Ministries met to
discuss some possible extraditions
demanded by Ankara
[Music]
and so despite the historical friction
everything seemed to be going smoothly
and so it was until January 2023 when
everything blew up yet again at that
time a Danish activist protested outside
the Turkish Embassy in Stockholm and
burned a copy of the Quran this sparked
major protests in many Arab countries
and unleashed the Wrath of the erdogan
government check it out we will not say
yes to Sweden's entry into NATO as long
as you allow a holy book the Quran to be
burnt torn apart and to be done with the
approval of your security Personnel of
course some may say that this was all
nothing more than a kind of second-rate
theatrics and so turkey's refusal all
this time to accept Sweden's accession
may have been a response not only to
ankara's poor relations with Stockholm
but above all with Washington yes yes
you heard me correctly with Washington
let me explain U.S turkey relations have
been pretty bad for years in fact
President Biden had several armed sales
packages to Turkey on the table for
months pending approval among them the
sale of the state of the art F-16
aircraft and since the US was so intent
on Sweden joining NATO once and for all
surprise U.S clears path for F-16 sales
to Turkey amid NATO expansion you see
turkey seems to have seized the
opportunity to put pressure on Uncle Sam
the other country that has also hindered
Sweden's integration has been hungry
erdogan and Orban what a Duo the fact is
within the framework of the European
Union Sweden is practically the
antithesis of Hungary in practically
everything from immigration to LGBT
policies to Social and environmental
policy or the position regarding the war
in Ukraine Sweden threatens to sue
Hungary over Asylum denials Sweden's
Justice Minister Morgan Johansen and
Sweden will challenge Hungary in court
unless it starts accepting Asylum
Seekers from other EU countries
sweden-hungary relations freeze as
diplomatic role escalates Sweden's
Social Democratic social affairs
minister Anika strandhall wrote on
Twitter that prime minister Victor
orbin's seven-point Family Planning
policy reeks of the 1930s and that what
is happening in Hungary is alarming why
why object to Sweden coming into NATO
because the political relation between
Sweden and Hungary is all fully wrong
and we have to improve first we will not
like to import conflicts into NATO first
so first manage the disagreements
between the two countries and then we
are ready to support them either as it
may in the end Sweden will join NATO and
the question is the most important
question of all and one that we have yet
to answer is why on Earth is the
accession of two relatively sparsely
populated countries like Sweden and
Finland so important for NATO why do we
say that this is a huge blow to Russia's
interests why did Moscow want to avoid
this scenario at all costs for years
well we're going to take a look at that
right now
[Music]
puzzle
look at what a 2016 report by the
estonia-based International Center for
defense and security set without Sweden
and Finland in NATO the alliance lacks
strategic and operational depth in the
region as well as sufficient capacity to
exercise greater control over sea and
airspace in the Baltic Sea if Russia
were to succeed in forcing Stockholm and
Helsinki to stay out of a Baltic
conflict needles response options would
become even more limited closing NATO's
Baltic Gap International Center for
defense and security but why is it so
important for Sweden and Finland to join
NATO well you can see the answer clearly
on this map
[Music]
following the annexation of Crimea in
2014 the United States conducted a
variety of War Games to look for
strategic weaknesses on NATO's borders
these games showed that the Swedish
island of gotland would play a key role
in the hypothetical case of having to
defend the Baltic republics if Russia
were to cut off the sawalki corridor and
seize gotland in order to deploy air
defense systems there as you can see on
the map the Baltic republics would be
practically trapped it would be very
difficult to come to their aid and it
would not even be necessary to go that
far with Russia preventing NATO from
using that Island a hybrid attack
against the baltics even with
unidentified troops as already happened
in Crimea could be a nightmare for the
Atlantic forces this is or rather was
one of Russia's great long-term Trump
cards
and that is not all
the integration of Finland and above all
Sweden into NATO also wipes out most of
Colleen ingrad's strategic value now
NATO could very easily cut off
Communications between this territory
and the rest of Russia let's just say
that the Russian Baltic fleets deployed
here ceases to be able to move freely
and not only that in such a conflict
scenario Russia would not even be able
to deliver supplies to this enclave and
take note because this reinforces the
idea that many analysts have that sooner
or later Colleen ingrad will end up
Beyond Russia's borders something we
will tell you about very soon on patreon
as a matter of fact the same is true for
the flow of goods in and out of the
global market Russia relies heavily on
trade across the Baltic to supply and
sell its products to the rest of the
world now those Communications will be
subject to NATO's approval and that's
not all either the Russian Air Force's
ability to reach positions in the rest
of Europe will also be severely limited
in other words while for decades the
Baltic Sea was a body of water
controlled by Russia that gave its Navy
and its Air Force access to the very
heart of Europe this is no longer the
case the integration of Finland and
Sweden into NATO has nipped that
possibility in the bud
in fact NATO Finland and Estonia have
already announced ambitious plans to
have the capacity to close the Gulf of
Finland if necessary also in 2022 Russia
announced plans to rebuild its Maritime
power in the area now those plans are
dead in the water with the entry of
Sweden and Finland into NATO the Baltic
Sea will be surrounded by NATO member
states the goal of establishing Russian
Maritime power proclaimed again in 2022
with the publication of the new Russian
naval Doctrine would now be unfeasible
in this strategically important region
the German Institute for international
and security Affairs and if with all
this Russia's Baltic Fleet is
practically history the future
integration of Ukraine into NATO would
make the same happen with the Black Sea
Fleet that is another matter sticking
with the subject of Sweden although this
country has a relatively small army it
brings to the alliance an important
military industry and keep in mind that
Swedish factories produce not only small
weapons but Advanced systems such as
combat aircraft missiles tank submarines
warships and air defense platforms we
believe that we will contribute to the
defense of the Allies we don't have an
armed forces as numerous as Finland but
we have the most Advanced Technologies
and very powerful defense companies tepo
tariana Swedish ambassador to Spain in
other words Sweden's accession to Nato
is without exaggeration one of the
biggest leaps in terms of security for
the whole of Europe in recent decades
Putin's special military operation saw
Russia go from sharing just 841
kilometers or 522 miles of borders with
nato in 2021 to more than 2 100
kilometers or 1 305 miles after
finland's entry now the integration of
Sweden will mean that it will basically
lose all of its influence in the Baltic
Sea the disaster in strategic terms is
colossal but now it's your turn how do
you think Russia will respond to
Sweden's NATO membership do you think
the next step should be to separate
Colleen ingrad from the rest of Russia
leave us your impressions in the in the
comments and let's open up a debate now
if you found this video interesting
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
visualpolitik if you haven't already
done so again thank you very much for
being here all the best and I'll see you
next time
[Music]
foreign